was saying thousands of ambulance
workers in England and Wales the staging
a fresh day of strikes today in their
ongoing dispute over pay and Staffing
they want double-digit wage increases to
help keep up with inflation but the
government says that is unaffordable
joined Now by The General Secretary of
the unite Union Sharon Graham hi Ms
Graham it's good to see you this morning
thanks for joining us um your members on
the picket lines again this morning how
are they feeling
well okay they're feeling very very
disappointed it's been five weeks since
unite ambulance workers were out on
strike and we believed what the
government said that they were serious
about resolution and in that five weeks
there has been absolutely no offer been
put on the table uh Rishi sunak is
missing in action it's very very clear
that he now needs to come to the table
as the CEO of UK PLC come to the table
and deal with this dispute
last week I think it was last Friday you
said the government is demonizing your
words ambulance workers about life and
limb cover what were you referring to
there
well um unfortunately ministers and I'm
going to use the word lie ministers have
lied continuously about ambulance
workers not doing life and limb cover
that is totally and utterly untrue I was
on the picket line in the West Midlands
and there was life in them cover people
were coming off the picket line to give
extra support in relation to that and
there's something where ministers are
beginning to lie in the middle of a
dispute and so therefore what I want
them to do and I want Rishi sunak now to
come to the table it's very clear Kay
that Stephen Barclay does not have any
Authority he doesn't have the authority
to do the deal there hasn't even been
one single offer in five weeks so we now
need Rishi Suna to take this seriously
this is the NHS get round the table
let's do the deal and let these people
go back to work
has there been any communication with
the Prime Minister either by you or
other representatives of the NHS unions
prime minister has absolutely not spoken
to us about this in any way shape or
form to be honest with you I haven't
seen him uh very often in the last five
weeks anywhere apart from in the back of
a car not wearing seatbelt and what he
needs to do now is he needs to come to
the table and do the deal that we need
to do to get these people back to work
this is his responsibility this is the
biggest abdication of leadership that I
have seen in negotiations ever in 30
years of negotiating he needs to do the
job he's paid for get round the table so
these people now can get back to work
you've called for the abolition of the
NHS pay review body I believe the
government would say that's an
independent peer review body that helps
decide how much money is available uh
for the the round of pay for NHS workers
um why do you want it abolished
okay with this and I think it's probably
um
now is that it isn't independent that is
really part of the problem but also the
scoping around it the government really
gives it such a steer that it can't
really come out of that straight jacket
and the government picks and chooses in
2014 it didn't accept the pay review
bodies recommendations in 2018 we're
negotiating with the government on
salaries fines so it really is picking
and choosing how it uses it what we
should do is what happens every other
negotiation I'm the leader of the
biggest private sector Union the private
sector wouldn't operate like this if
there's negotiations of this of this
caliber the CEO would be in a room with
me would be negotiating and would put a
deal back to the members that's what the
government needs to do now either Rishi
sunak is not up to the job and he
doesn't know how to negotiate or there
is something more Sinister going on here
so I'm calling him to come to the table
sit down with General secretaries let's
get a deal on the table and then we can
give that deal back to our members to
vote on
I think it's fair to say that it's
becoming very clear that the government
is unlikely to budge on a pay deal this
year you're only um two or three months
away from next year's negotiations by
that I mean um April 2023 is now the
time to put a pin in this and start
negotiating better deal for next year
well that would mean that these workers
didn't get a pay rise for 22 and 23 and
to be honest with you we cannot allow
that to happen you know it sounds like
white noise but these were the people
that were put out there in the pandemic
when we didn't have a vaccine nobody
knew what was going to go on people were
dying NHS workers died and I think it's
a National Disgrace an absolute National
Disgrace that we are not giving these
these workers a proper pay rise so we
are going to be here until the
government comes to its senses and
decides to talk about 22 and 23. they
need to come back to the negotiating
table and put an offer in they've been
around your studio okay saying they're
in constructive talks and they are
talking about offers we've had no offer
and unfortunately I can't put the words
constructive talks in the ballot paper I
need to have a deal that I can put back
to the members so that they can then
ballot and everybody can go back to work
what what does um increased
um industrial action look like though
because obviously what you're doing at
the moment is not making the government
budge at all what what more can you do
well I suppose the 6th of February is
um you know quite a sad day for the NHS
this is obviously a day when you're
going to have paramedics NHS workers
across the piece nurses all coming out
together which is the first time that
that's happened we've tried to sort of
make the strikes happen when we don't
come out all at the same time so that
that's better for the service now what I
would hope is that the government at the
very least if they're not listening to
the NHS workers at the very least listen
to the public the surveys are clearly
showing that the public who by the way
are their voters want them to sort this
out and they agree that they should get
a pay rise so if Rishi sunak decides to
ignore the public then I think that will
cost him badly at The Ballot Box what
they need to do now is to listen to the
public listen to the workforce come
around the table do a negotiation that
we can put back to our members we are
compromising they can hear that in terms
of what we're saying come to the table
and let's see if we can get a deal
if lives are lost on the 6th of February
when ambulance workers emergency call
handlers and nurses all come out on
strike on the same day who will be
responsible for that
well look the first thing I'd say well
the government fairly and squarely but
the first thing I would say is I really
hope the 6th of February does not happen
there's a lot of days between now and
the 6th of February the government has
an opportunity anytime they want to
bring the general secretaries in a room
we will all be there at a drop of the
Hat we'll cancel and we'll clear all
Diaries to do it but even on the 6th of
February we are going to make sure that
we have life and in cover but I would
say this cake is it's an important
figure 500 people
500 people are dying every single week
waiting for an ambulance in the fifth
richest economy in the world that is an
absolute National Disgrace
it's not helping though is it when your
members go out on strike
but I suppose what um what we would say
to that case what else we've got to do
we're trying to talk to them we're
trying to bring them around a table
we're trying to say come and negotiate
which would be doing everything we can
to get them to come to the table and
they're absolutely refusing but I have
to say this is about pay of course it is
absolutely about pay but it's also about
the very existence of the NHS how could
we have a situation on a normal day
where no strike is taking place
whatsoever that 500 people are dying in
Britain every week waiting for an
ambulance that is unbelievable that that
is happening in our country so we have
to put a stake in the ground we have to
defend the NHS and the public wants us
to do that also
okay we must leave it there um thank you
for taking the time to join us this
morning do keep us in touch with any
movement on these continuing strikes
thanks a lot